[MUSIC PLAYING]
SRINATH PADMANABHAN:
To get started,
I just want to tell you
all something that I truly
feel from the heart.
I really love these
kind of events,
and I want to thank each
and every one of you
for being here because these
events are really, really
useful and effective ways
for us to talk to customers.
So every time we
come to a Google
Next-- like for instance,
when we came here last year,
we had this opportunity
to come talk to all of you
and listen to some of your
feedback about what's working
well, what's not,
what can be changed,
what can we do better, what
should we continue to focus on,
and we take all of
this feedback and then
we go back to our day jobs
and we start looking at all
of this, and of course
we take a little bit
of a break in between,
but we go back the
next week and we
started looking at all
of these lists of things
that we heard from you in
terms of what's working well
and what's not.
And we use this to kind of be
a roadmap for the next year.
So we really focus on areas
where you say we're doing well
and areas where you
say we need to improve
and try to make
something that really
helps solve those problems.
And that's why I am really
excited to come back here today
and talk to you about
what we learned last year
and what we've been able to
deliver in terms of things
that help simplify
your lives and help
build on our partnership.
So with that, I
want to start off
by saying, what were
some of the key things
that we heard from
all of you last year?
So we heard various
things from you,
but if I were to distill
them down onto one slide,
these are some of
the key pinpoints
that you talked about.
One of the things we
heard a lot was you
wanted us to meet
you where you were.
You wanted us to make it easier
for you to get onto the cloud
or to reach the cloud.
And as you might have
noticed in today's keynote,
a lot of what we've
done over the past year
has been in that
very area, where
we talk about bringing
the cloud to you
rather than kind of having
you move things over
or looking at things
in a different way.
The second thing that we've
heard a lot from people
was, help simplify
my transition.
It doesn't matter
whether you're trying
to transition a whole
bunch of workloads
or you're trying to transition
just small pieces of things
that you're running
somewhere into Google Cloud.
So you asked us to help
simplify the transition,
and that has been one of
our key focuses as well
and I'll definitely go into
some interesting ways we've
been able to do that.
We also got two really
nice pieces of feedback.
You said that you really
like how we price things
and how flexible we
are in terms of costs
and making offerings
available in a very, very
cost-effective manner.
And we also heard from
you that we do really
well when it comes to
security and trying
to provide a nice footprint and
a nice kind of ecosystem that
lets you build your security
story on top of that.
And so we've doubled down
on both of these areas
and tried to do more
to help make these more
useful and more better for you.
So with that, I'm
going to start off
by talking about something
that we at Google Cloud
really feel is a big
differentiator for us
and it's something
that we focus on
and we want to
continue to focus on,
and that is our
global infrastructure.
So Google Cloud has been
building this infrastructure
for many, many years,
from even before when
we were Google Cloud.
So we've been building
these submarine cables
and we've been building
these data centers
and we've gotten to this
point where, this year, we're
so proud to announce that we
have 17 regions that are up
and we have 125 points of
presence around the globe.
And this goes to
make that transition
to the cloud much
easier because each
and every one of these
points of presence
is one additional
location that's closer
to where your customers are--
your customers who are consuming
your applications which
run in Google Cloud.
And what we do to tie
all of this together
is we have this
extensive network
of submarine cable
and terrestrial cables
that connect all of
these points of presence
and our data centers
and various other pieces
that we provide for
you together to make
it one huge infrastructure
investment that delivers value
to all of you.
And over the years,
as we've been building
these sub-sea cables and
all of these investments
have been made in
the cable world,
have gotten us to
the point where
we have an extensive
team that's completely
focused on submarine cables.
And I'm really,
really proud to talk
about the next slide, which
is something very unique
that we did this year.
So, in January of
this year, we became
the first non-telco
company to announce
a completely private
sub-sea cable that
connects two continents.
And this was the Curie sub-sea
cable, named after Marie Curie,
and it connects Los
Angeles to Chile.
And I'm also very, very excited
to announce that-- well,
not announce, but last week,
we announced the Dunant sub-sea
cable.
This is again named after the
founder of the Red Cross, Andre
Dunant, and it connects the
east coast of the US to Europe.
So this is the first
trans-Atlantic cable
that's actually, again,
owned completely privately
by a non-telco entity.
So this just goes to
show some of these things
that we're trying to
do to bring more value
from our infrastructure to you.
So just looking at
the numbers in terms
of what we've been doing with
respect to infrastructures,
I'm going to point out
a few key numbers here.
We've been spending
a lot of money
in terms of making this
infrastructure that underlies
our Google Cloud, and
over the past three years,
we've spent over $30
billion in terms of expenses
to build out Google's
infrastructure.
In addition, we've also
got twenty cloud regions
that we've announced.
We have 125 points of
presence, which I talked about.
We're going to go into
the dedicated interconnect
locations shortly as well,
but the really interesting
statistic here is the 100,000
miles of fiber optic cable
that we have.
This is, if you look at all
of the fiber optic cables
that we've deployed across
the globe, it's 100,000 miles.
That's, just to
put it in context,
about a little bit over
a third of the distance
from here to the moon.
So it's a lot of investment
in terms of these cables
and what I hope to
do is to tell you
a little bit about why
this adds value to you
and your deployments
running on Google Cloud.
So all of this infrastructure
is the underlay
that lets us build our SDN
ecosystem on top of that,
using things that you've
probably heard about,
like Andromeda and
Espresso, and if you
want to learn more
about this, I definitely
recommend that you go and attend
one of two sessions that we
have later in the
conference which
dive much deeper into this area
and about how it helps improve
performance of
different workloads
that are running in the cloud,
and in terms of networking,
how it makes it so efficient.
But if I were to point
out three key things here,
the first thing is, this lets
us provide this global network
and the construct
of the global VPC
that I'll talk about in a
minute, which basically takes
away a lot of your sprawl and
toil from managing a vast cloud
deployment.
It gives you a global
reach by getting you
to a point very, very close
to where your customers are
and it also gives you various
benefits, like live migration.
With live migration,
what we're able to do
is be able to keep
your VMs up when
we need to do something like,
say, a firmware update that
needs to be done on the
underlying infrastructure.
And some of these things
really make it very easy
to deploy on Google
Cloud and help
your workloads keep running.
And finally, because
of the way we
have all of this infrastructure
investment laid out
and we have this SDN
architecture built
on top of that, it also
helps things scale seamlessly
because every single piece
of our networking offering
is built in such a way that
there are no chokepoints.
Everything is built in
a distributed manner
to make it very, very
easy for you to scale.
And we've continued to innovate
in this area with something
that we've announced
late last year,
which was Andromeda
2.1, which has actually
reduced our intra-zone latency
by 40% from Andromeda 2.0,
and if you look at
it overall, it's
about a 780% reduction in
terms of the latency going
from when we originally started
and introduced Andromeda.
So we talked about
this infrastructure.
Now let me go a
little bit deeper
into how this infrastructure
helps you build your cloud
deployment.
And we're going to look
at some interesting things
we've done over the
past year and how
we help solve various
of those problems
that we talked about
in the beginning.
So to begin with, I want
to talk about two pieces--
our Virtual Private Cloud
and our connectivity options.
So when you look at Google
Cloud's VPC, the global VPC
that we provide, it's very,
very unique in the sense
that it provides you a
connectivity by default
across all of your
workloads that you
have running in Google Cloud, no
matter which region you're on.
So what I have there is
a simple one sentence,
where if I were
to describe this,
the way I would do that is
you may have 17 regions--
you may have VMs running in
each and every one of these 17
regions--
but you have one VPC,
which means you have
to manage one set of policies.
You have to manage
one set of security.
You need to do all of your
security configurations
and everything once.
And it really makes
it much easier
for you to manage your
truly global deployment.
Now the other really
nice thing about this
is, since this is built in
this way, the only way we
are able to make something
like this work is because
of the infrastructure offerings
that we provide that gives you
the kind of performance
that you really
need to pull something
off like this.
Now let's look at what are
some different things that you
can do to connect to the
global VPC from your network.
So we've had various
offerings, and this year, we
talked about two key offerings,
which was the Google Cloud
Interconnect offerings.
And when you look at Google
Cloud Interconnect, what
it does is these are
various offerings that
help you connect from
wherever you are,
whether it's a data center
or whether you're looking
at a co-location facility.
It gives you a
convenient way for you
to connect from where
you are to Google Cloud.
And the way you
would do this is you
would connect to one of our many
dedicated Interconnect points
of presence, and
once you do that, you
will be on the
Google Cloud network
for the rest of the way.
The other interesting thing
I want to quickly touch upon
before diving deeper into
Google Cloud Interconnect is we
have also been
working on simplifying
all of your connectivity
options, including VPN.
We've had a lot of
efforts that we've
invested in working
with our partners,
and with our
partners, we've been
able to deliver to this whole
slew of integration guides
and making it extremely easy for
you to spin up any kind of VPN
connectivity when you want
to connect to Google Cloud.
So I mentioned about
Dedicated Interconnect.
So let me tell you
what we think makes
Dedicated Interconnect unique.
So when you look at
a connectivity option
where you need to
connect to a cloud,
let's imagine that you
have a data center here
in San Francisco and
you have workloads
that are running in
different regions.
Let's say you have one
running in Los Angeles,
you have one running
in Singapore,
and you have one running
somewhere in Europe.
So just pick any three
data centers of your choice
and imagine that you
have this deployed.
Now if you were trying to
do a dedicated connectivity
from your data
center to the cloud,
to each one of these
regions, usually you
would have to deploy
one set of connections
to each and every
one of these regions.
With Dedicated Interconnect,
what you are able to do
is you're actually able to
connect from your data center
to the nearest region.
So in this case, you would
just connect to the Los Angeles
region, and from there, you
can ride Google's backbone
to get to whichever other
data center that you need to.
The other really
nice thing about this
is it greatly
simplifies the sprawl
and toil that come
from trying to build
these kind of deployments with
multiple connections going
to all of these
different regions.
So this map shows all of
our Dedicated Interconnect
locations.
So no matter where
you are, there
are these various locations
where you need to get to
and we bring you onto
the Google Cloud network
right from those points.
We also work with
various partners and each
and every one of these
partners helps us provide you
with a much more simplified way
of connecting to Google Cloud.
So for instance, if
you were to connect
to any one of
these partners, you
get the flexibility to choose
the bandwidth that you need,
and they will help you
connect from wherever
you are to Google Cloud.
So we talked about
how we've been trying
to simplify your
connectivity options when
you're trying to go from
your on-premise to the cloud.
Now let's look at
what we've been
doing in terms of helping you
deliver applications better.
So when you talk about
application delivery,
these are a few offerings
that we usually talk about,
and I'm going to spend
a few minutes talking
about what we've done in each
of these over the past year.
So first, let's take a look
at Google Cloud's Global Load
Balancing.
So we built Google Cloud's
Global Load Balancing based off
all of the lessons
that we learned over
the years in terms of building
and delivering applications
like Gmail and Google
Search and YouTube and all
of these different
offerings, and you'll also
notice that that's
actually true for each
and every one of
these things that we
look at in the application
delivery portfolio.
And when you see this, we
got a lot of great feedback
in terms of how the Google
Cloud Load Balancer works
and how it makes it
extremely simple to manage
a scalable load
balancing deployment,
and we've kind of tried to
take that over the last year
and go to the next step.
So our Google Cloud
Load Balancer,
for those of you who aren't
familiar with it, supports
Global Anycast IP
load balancing,
which means rather than
having to use your own DNS
service to load balance
to multiple IP addresses
depending on where your
traffic is coming from,
you can use your load balancer
to use a single Global Anycast
IP so that if you have a user,
for instance, in this example
who is trying to get onto
the Google Cloud network
to reach your application
from San Francisco,
they would still be using the
same IP address, as you would
see for a customer who's trying
to connect to your Google Cloud
deployment from Singapore,
but the services would
be provided by the data
center that's closest to them.
So this does various things,
and the first and foremost
is it greatly simplifies what
you need to do on the DNS front
in terms of configuring
and managing a deployment
like this.
Now the really cool
thing that we've
done in this area
in the past year
is we've enhanced a lot of
different protocol supports
that we've added over the
past year, and one of them
specifically that I want to call
out is our support for QUIC.
So QUIC actually
is a protocol that
would help you gain a lot in
terms of your connectivity time
and in terms of the
latency that it actually
takes for your users to
get onto this application
that you're looking for.
So for instance, we see
about an 8% decrease
in terms of page
load times globally,
and especially if
you're in an area where
there is a lot of
latency or you're
in high latency environment,
it goes up much higher--
it's about 13% in
those kind of areas.
So we do have a great
session about load balancing
that's happening later
in the conference
as well, where we go much
deeper into this area
and many other things about
our load balancing offering.
Google Cloud DNS is built to
work with our load balancer
so it works out
really, really well
in this particular deployment,
where it integrates seamlessly
with our Global Anycast
load balancing offering.
It also has a very, very simple
scalable record management
and it also supports
DNSSEC so that you
can verify the integrity
of your records
when your clients are trying
to connect to your setup.
Now let's look at Google Cloud's
Content Delivery Network.
So like I mentioned, our
content delivery system as well
is built off of a
lot of the things
that we've learned over the
years from YouTube and Google
Search and all of
our other offerings.
And what we've been
able to do here
is to try and take
some of those lessons
and bring to you a very,
very scalable global approach
to delivering your
content across the globe.
So one thing that we've
done over the past year
is we recently announced support
for very, very large-sized
objects, which makes it great
for media and applications
where you're trying to either
deliver media or gaming.
So this is again something great
that we're very, very proud of,
and we do have a
session about CDN
as well if you're
interested in learning more
about this offering.
We announced network
tiers at Next last year.
Network tiers is now in
beta and network tiers
is basically what makes
your global VPC work.
So the network
tiers is an offering
that lets your traffic
travel Google's network
all the way through from
the source to your end user
until a point of presence
that's very, very close to them.
So by doing this, it's
able to provide you
with much better latency
and much better performance
than you would be
used to on a regular--
when you're using
the public internet.
So last year we heard from
you that-- and sometimes there
are certain work loads where
this extra performance is not
necessarily what
you are looking for
and you would look for more
cost-effective offerings,
so that's where we
introduced the standard tier,
and the standard tier
is currently beta.
And usually when you
look at customers
and when they use
premium network
versus standard network,
our customers really
like to use the premium network
for any live applications
or applications that are being
accessed by their end users,
whereas in a lot
of cases, they like
to use the standard network for
things like a test deployment
where you're trying
to build something
and making changes in your
development environment.
So those kind of
environments usually
use the standard
network, as opposed
to the premium network for
the production environment.
Now we talked about
connecting to the cloud
and we talked about
delivering your applications
to your customers.
Next, we're going to
look at various things
that we have been doing
in the area of securing
your deployments.
So we got a lot
of great feedback
in terms of how we've been
making more and more offerings
available in terms of
security for our users,
and in this area, we focused
on a few specific things
to try and make those very, very
user-friendly and very, very
easy.
So the first one is
VPC Service Controls.
So what VPC Service
Controls does
is it greatly mitigates any
kind of exfiltration risk
you may have by
providing you controls
which are context-aware
and let you
enforce policy for accessing
files not just based
on the identity of the user
but also based on the context.
So this gives you much more
visibility into your data,
which is the lifeblood
of your business,
and it really helps you control
where this data is flowing.
Network monitoring is one area
where we got a lot of feedback
from our customers, saying
that when you look at a cloud
deployment and you look
at network monitoring
offerings that are
available there,
one big concern
for our customers
was that it doesn't map one
to one when you get started
in terms of what we have
with the level of visibility
that you look at in
the cloud as opposed
to what you look at when
you're doing something on-prem.
And so we took that
and we went back
and we tried to
build this offering
and we announced
VPC Flow Logs, which
is now generally available,
and with VPC Flow Logs, what
you can do is you get
five-second interval updates.
So this is almost as
responsive as what you
would see in your data centers.
And the really nice thing about
doing something like this is it
lets you have the same
level of visibility
that you would when you're
deploying things in your data
center and it
integrates seamlessly
with all of your deployments
that you have on-prem as well,
because we partner with many
of our security partners
to provide visibility
into these logs.
So what you could
do is you could
export these logs to
your partner ecosystem
that you're already using and
have a single pane of glass
where you can visualize both
your traffic in your data
center as well as what
you're using in the cloud.
And what helps us make
this even more flexible
is that we have a very,
very rich set of parameters
that we provide to you in terms
of filtering this flow log.
So we let you annotate
based on things
like the geolocation
of your client
who is trying to
access the service,
the region where
your VM is running,
and various other
things like the subnet
things that let
you get the logs that
you're really looking for
and just use those in
order to keep a close eye
and get great visibility
into the security
posture of your deployment.
The next thing we're going
to talk about is Cloud Armor.
Cloud Armor is our denial
of service defense system
that we've built and we
announced in March this year,
and in fact, we have
a session later today
where Nick will also be
presenting about Target
and how they have been using
the Cloud Armor service as well.
So there are a few
key things I want
to point out about Cloud Armor.
So Cloud Armor is built
to integrate very,
very closely with
our load balancer,
so what tends to happen is
we are able to take away
a brunt of any kind
of a layer three DDoS
attack that would try to
hit you at the load balancer
Then beyond that, we have
denial of service defense
that is built to protect
you against application
attacks and various
things like SQL injection
and cross-site scripting.
So Cloud Armor provides
you with a rules language
that lets you program
things beyond things
like SQL injection and
cross-site scripting,
where you can
tailor your security
policy to fit
exactly what you are
doing on your own deployment.
And the nice thing about
the way Cloud Armor is built
is that a lot of
this defense actually
happens at the
perimeter, which means
it makes it much easier
for you to manage
the scale of your setup
while using something
like Cloud Armor.
So we talked about all of
these different offerings.
We talked about our connectivity
offerings, the security
that we try to provide to
you with your networking
deployments, how you can get
your applications delivered
to your customer.
So in this next
section, I'm going
to talk about the
workload of your choice.
So we have been having more and
more customers adopt Kubernetes
and we have a lot of customers
who have been adopting GKE,
and they're really adopting
container technologies
and making them their own.
So what we've been
focusing on is
we've been trying to make
Google Cloud the cloud of choice
to run your micro-services.
So we are trying to
provide native support
for every single networking
service that we have
and networking offering that
we have for Kuberetes Engine.
Like, for instance, this
year we have support--
Kubernetes Engine supports
Global Load Balancing,
it supports our denial
of service product,
which is Cloud Armor.
It supports IAP
and our CDN, and we
are committed to making
sure that every one
of our networking offerings
is available for you
with Kubernetes Engine as well.
And we've also
taken the next step
in terms of securing Kubernetes
workload so that you can look
at your security whether
you're looking at containers
or you're looking at compute.
You can look at them
in the same way.
So we announced
support for things
like shared VPC,
private clusters,
we support network policies,
distributed firewalls,
VPC flow logging--
all of these are
supported natively
now with Kubernetes, which
makes it extremely easy for you
to manage your security
policies whether you're
doing Compute Engine or
Container Engine deployments.
And if you're looking to
connect your different services,
I'm sure you already
heard about some
of this in today
morning's keynote
and you're going to hear a lot
more over the next few days
in terms of various sessions
where people are going
to talk to you about
Istio and Kubernetes
and what they're
doing in these areas
to really make it easy to
use, manage, and secure.
And to this point,
we also have support
for all of these things
in different ways
in our networking offerings,
so like for instance,
in our networking
team, we also have
the gRPC under our
portfolio, which
lets you connect basically your
services in terms of RPC calls
and making sure that it's
extremely easy for you
to build a service
without having
to put all the brunt off
the effort of building
and deploying the
networking aspects of this
on your developers.
So what you can do is
you can use ecosystems
like Istio and gRPC and make
it available to your developers
so that they can focus on
building the applications
without having to worry a
lot about the networking
and securing the network
communication parts, which
can be taken care of, then, by
your security admins, who would
use tools like Istio
and gRPC to make sure
that this communication
is secured.
We also have a lot of partners
in the areas of security
and we're working with adding
many, many more every day.
We keep talking to
different partners
and we try to see
how we can integrate
with them to make a better
offering available to you
every single day.
And so this is just a quick
snapshot of various partners
that we have in
the security space,
and I'm sure you
recognize a lot of names
there, so we do
work with them very,
very closely to make
Google Cloud a very, very
partner-friendly offering when
it comes to network security.
So with that, I
just want to recap
by saying thank you so
much for all the feedback
that you gave us
in the last year
and it's really helped
us empower your success
by trying to come
and make it easier
for you to move to the cloud
by meeting you where you are
and providing you these
secure and flexible
yet simple and reliable
offerings that can really
work for any workload that
you're looking to use.
And with that, I
definitely want to also say
I'm really looking forward
to talking to all of you
and hearing what you have in
mind for us for the next year
and what you would like to
hear about when we come back
to Next 2019 next year.
So now I'm going to
call Nick on stage
to come and talk about what
a lot of these offerings
meant from a
customer perspective.
NICK JACQUES: Thank you.
All right.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Nick Jacques.
I am a lead engineer
at Target and I work
on our cloud platform team.
I'm really excited to be here
today and chat with everyone
about some of the things
that we're doing in GCP.
So just a little bit about
who I am and what Target is.
So Target is a rather popular
retailer here in the US.
We have 1,800 stores,
several distribution centers,
a few headquarters,
locations, and then
we also have one very big
virtual store, Target.com.
I've been working on our cloud
platform team for about 2
and 1/2, 3 years now,
and prior to that,
I was on a couple of our
different infrastructure teams
dealing with enterprise
storage and virtualization,
private cloud build-out, all
kinds of good stuff like that.
The reason why we thought it'd
be really appropriate to share
some of this with you is Target
started its journey in GCP
in early 2017.
So it's been a
little over a year
since we really have
migrated to GCP and Earnest,
so we thought that
kind of lined up
with the discussion about what's
new over the past year in GCP.
Just to give you a little
time table, in very early
2017 is when we started
migrating our workloads
from another cloud
provider into GCP,
and we were able
to complete that I
want to say around
late July, mid-August,
so right in time
for peak season.
We had a very successful
peak season with no issues
and everyone was really
happy about that.
Early this year,
we had discussions
around where we were going to
migrate our commerce workloads.
So we kind of split these
into two categories.
What non-commerce means for us
is, when you're on Target.com
or if you're using
one of our apps,
it's basically
anything that doesn't
involve purchasing products.
So if you're searching
for products,
if you're swiping through
looking at images of products,
things like that, that's
what we call non-commerce.
And then when we actually have
you add items to your cart,
check out, and then
pay for those items,
those are kind of
the commerce things.
Those tend to be a little more
difficult to do because there's
quite a bit of regulatory
compliance involved with them.
So we started migrating our
commerce workloads in Earnest
right around the middle
of this year, probably
around March or April, and
actually, we're almost 100%
complete with that so we're
pretty excited that we
have almost all the things that
power Target.com in GCP right
now.
So just to give you kind of
the gamut of what's in there,
we have quite a
bit that's there.
A lot of these services that
I list under Target.com are
actually shared and our
mobile apps use those services
to display content as well,
but we have everything from
our adaptive frontend-- so
basically giving you responsive
design depending on what
you're using-- desktop, laptop,
tablets, mobile devices,
things like that--
and also our backends.
Our backends kind
of spread the gamut
between things that are
very monolithic-- they're
kind of standalone
apps-- to some very
complicated applications
that have upwards of three
or four dozen micro-services.
We also operate a
data persistence layer
and provide replication services
to and from our data center
and a platform for
logging in metrics.
These last three items--
the data persistence,
replication,
and logging in metrics--
are part of what we refer
to as platform services
and that's part of what my team
helps offer our application
teams or our tenants in GCP.
We provide a suite of services
that any application team
can use and basically
provides common functionality
around any cloud
that we deploy to.
So it abstracts a lot
of the difficulties
away from our application
teams in terms of figuring out
how to do service discovery,
where to store data,
how to replicate data,
things like that,
and really lets them focus
on building their apps
and then deploying those
apps and not really
having to worry about some of
that underlying infrastructure.
And then, as I
mentioned, we also
operate some of our
commerce stuff in GCP,
and so those things are PCI
DSS compliant, which obviously
means that there is a great
deal of regulatory compliance
that's attached to it,
and those environments
are highly segmented.
For mobile apps-- so in
addition to everything
that we just talked
about for Target.com,
we also have some
unique mobile offerings,
so we have things
like Cartwheel,
which is part of
our mobile app that
lets you discover coupons
and various discounts that
are available in the store.
Wallet, which is
actually really great.
It allows you to take all those
coupons and discounts that you
discover with Cartwheel
and pay with your red card
in a single scan of a
barcode so it's really handy.
I use it all the time.
And then we also provide some
other interesting services,
like in-store mapping.
So we can tell you where
a particular product is
that you're searching
for in a store
and then actually show
where you are in the store
and you can kind of find
your way to that product.
There are a few other
mobile apps as well.
And then we also host a
variety of API endpoints.
So we actually host our
developer documentation
at developer.target.com on
GCP, as well as a variety
of API backends in GCP.
So these are everything
from item availability,
creating shipping labels,
creating barcodes,
things like that.
We also host a variety
of static content.
So think images,
JavaScript files,
all kinds of stuff like
that, in GCS buckets,
and we also use Cloud DNS.
So I sat for a while and
tried to think about,
how can I best communicate
all the various features
that we use in terms of
networking and infrastructure
in GCP?
And I thought for a while
about this and ultimately
what I decided to do is turn
to a tool that a lot of people
use in large companies when
they're making decisions, which
is a particular geometric
shape that tends to be or have
magical properties.
So I looked at this--
and I definitely
didn't make this on a plane.
This is very official.
And what I saw was that word
cloud, for the eighth year,
is dominating the information
density representation.
So with that in mind, here
are some of the features
that we use in terms of
networking and infrastructure
for Target.
So there's quite a few up here.
I'm not going to go through them
all now because we'll actually
kind of just naturally
go through those as we
work through these slides.
So briefly what I
want to talk about
are the environments
that we have.
So as I mentioned, our
non-commerce environment
has to do a lot with basically
browsing and discovering
products and services
on Target.com.
So the way those are structured,
we have several environments.
So we have a dev environment,
a non-prod for staging
and performance
purposes environment,
and then we have a
production environment.
And you can think of
those environments
basically as single
monolithic projects.
Inside of those projects,
there is a single VPC
that contains many
different regional subnets,
and what we've done is something
kind of interesting here.
One of the challenges
we've previously
encountered in prior
cloud providers
and just due to the
nature of Target
itself is IP address exhaustion.
So particularly in
a cloud, you want
to be able to scale and
not run into any issues
where you've exhausted a
subnet and now what do you do.
So to get around
those challenges,
because these
tenants are actually
quite large in size and
scale through many thousands
of instances, is we
actually kind of divorced
the application subnets from
our data center routeability.
So what that means is
all of our applications
that operate in our non-commerce
environment are basically
air-gapped from the data
center, but what that means
for us is we've created several
very large subnets so we don't
have to worry about partitioning
off specific applications
and specific subnets
or things like that.
It's just a very large
general-purpose hosting
environment.
The way that we allow
the applications to talk
to services in our data
center or replicate data
across is that platform
services suite of components
that I mentioned earlier.
Those services are data
center routeable and so
that's how we replicate
that data across,
and then the application
teams can consume it in GCP.
If we take a look, then, at
our commerce environment,
that environment is
actually quite different.
Yes, it's still hosted
in GCP, and yes, we still
have our platform
services there,
but many things beyond
that are different.
So, for compliance
purposes, we wanted
to make sure that we had a
highly segmented environment
here.
So what we've done is we've
actually created many projects
and we've used shared
VPC and VPC peering
to give us that really
highly segmented environment
and help us partition off each
individual application that
runs there.
In this model, all
of our instances
are data center routeable,
and we made that choice
because this
environment is actually
at least an order
of magnitude smaller
than our non-commerce
environment,
and many of those applications
have direct requirements
for synchronous or asynchronous
calls to our data center
to complete things like
payment transactions and so on.
So we needed to give
those applications a way
to directly hook
into the data center.
As I mentioned, these
tenants are highly segmented
and basically everything
in this environment
is subject to
regulatory compliance.
So obviously we wanted to make
sure that we got it right.
Going through some of
the common patterns
that we have across both
of these environments,
we currently use IPsec VPNs
to connect our data centers
to these particular
environments.
One of the things
that we're looking at,
which was mentioned just a bit
ago, is partner interconnect,
and that's something
that we're investigating
and we'll be taking
a deeper look at that
either later this
year or early 2019.
We also use Cloud DNS
basically across all
of our environments
in GCP and that
hosts the authoritative DNS
for our internal resources
as well as our
external resources.
Our developers are
a really big fan
of this because
this means that they
can use a common consolidated
Terraform repository
to create DNS entries
for their applications
and they don't need to cut
tickets to another team
to create DNS entries
and wait for another team
to complete those tasks.
So we really empower developers
by letting them create
their DNS entries themselves.
For any type of
situation where instances
need to reach out
to the internet,
and this is actually
fairly common given
that API.Target.com is
surfaced on the internet,
we provide either a
NAT or a proxy service.
So these services
are instrumented
with packet capturing
software and they basically
allow us to police
traffic that's
egressing our caught environment
and take a look at what's
going on there so that we can
react to it should anything
happen.
As I mentioned
several times already,
our platform services
are consistent across all
of these environments.
We also use the HTTPS load
balancers almost universally.
I would say that
there are probably
six load balancers that are
not the L7 load balancers.
We love them.
They're great.
They give us an
Anycast IP address,
we operate services
in multiple regions,
and all we do is wire those
services up with the same load
balancer and away we go.
We don't have to worry about, is
this IP address in this region
and how do we
geolocate our users
and make sure that they're going
to the region close to them.
It's all handled through
that load balancer.
The way that we let our
application teams manage
their deployments and manage
the instances they're running on
is through an open-source
tool called Spinnaker.
It's a really great
tool and I would highly
encourage you to
check it out if you're
able to use it in your
particular environment.
It really takes away a lot
of the pain of creating
a deployment pattern.
You don't have to worry
about having people
login to an instance and run
scripts or anything like that.
Basically, you create some sort
of package install deliverable,
Spinnaker will bake that into
an instance template for you,
and then you can deploy that
as many times as you would like
and deploy it in
multiple instance groups
and it makes things really
easy, so I would highly
recommend that.
One of the things that
we use fairly heavily
is private IP Google access.
The reason why we use
this heavily is almost
every instance in
GCP that we operate
does not have a public
or external IP address.
Our NATs and proxies are
there for that purpose,
and so what we want to do
is keep all that traffic,
especially traffic
that's destined to APIs,
for example, to GCS, just
internal to our VPCs.
So we use private IP
Google access for that.
We collect and analyze
logs across all
of these environments.
And then finally, we use
Cloud Armor and SSL policies
to make sure that our
load balancers at the edge
match our security posture
that we'd like them to have.
So for instance, only accepting
TLS version 1.2 connections,
things like that.
So we've talked
through a lot of lists.
What I want to do
is give you a visual
that we can take a look at.
So at a very high
level, this is what
our non-commerce
environment looks like.
So what we have
in our application
hosting area that's not
really pictured here
are several subnets that
span multiple regions.
But roughly what happens
is we have a Layer 7 load
balancer that fronts
our various endpoints.
So it could be an application
with multiple URL routes.
It could be just a
single-purpose app
or a micro-service.
And then we have that partition
for platform services again.
So again, there's things
like service discovery
that we host in there, data
persistence, data replication,
things like that.
Then, as pictured, we have a VPN
that connects this environment
to our data center,
and you'll notice
that we've attached only the
platform services subnets
to our data center.
The application
hosting subnets really
only talk to our platform
services and that's about it.
Then finally, the part that
we haven't touched on yet
is, what do we do with
requests that are inbound?
How do we actually
service requests
from either our guests or API
calls or things like that?
How this works is we
have our clients--
they might be our guests,
they might be a third party
that's using our APIs--
and the first step is
they'll hit our CDN provider.
So our CDN provider is
effectively our edge.
And through there, in a variety
of caching and web application
firewall layers, eventually
we'll traverse back into GCP
and we'll hit one of
these load balancers
that represents a particular
service that we're hosting.
So that's kind of things for
our non-commerce environment
in a nutshell.
If we go over to our
commerce environment,
pay really close attention
because the picture is going
to look fairly
similar, but what you
notice is we have a lot
more boxes down here
on the left-hand side.
So what we've done is we've used
shared VPC and what we've done
is we've partitioned out
each of these applications
into its own service project.
So what that means
is our application
teams, through Spinnaker, have
full reign in their service
project to do deployments
that they would need to do
and they can look at
all of the logs that
are collected via Stackdriver.
This partitioning puts
us in a really good place
wherein application
teams can't look
at other app teams logs, right?
You can only see
the logs that are
relevant to the workloads that
are operating in your project.
So that's been working
out very nicely for us.
We've done the exact same thing
with our platform services
as well, so no one is
immune to the segmentation
and partitioning.
So each of our
platform services teams
that operates each one of
these particular services
that we provide has their
own service project as well.
And then what we've done and
the great part about shared VPC
is we consolidated all
of our network policy
into the host project.
So what that means is all of
our custom routes are there,
our VPN connections
are there but apply
to all of these service
projects as well,
and then our firewall
rules are there as well.
So the great thing about this
is we have a centralized place
for firewall rules, we don't
need to go hunting around
to see if a particular
application team has changed
a firewall rule, and in
fact, the application teams
can't change a firewall
rule because the service
projects won't allow it.
So all of those firewall
rules are hosted and kind
of consolidated in
the host project
and then we provide our
developers again a Terraform
repository through which
they can enact those changes.
In this particular case,
they are heavily reviewed
and we ensure the safety before
we put those into effect.
And then the rest of
it is very similar.
We have VPNs that connect
us to the data center.
In this case, on this GCP side,
anything can traverse the VPN
and come back to the
Target data center.
And then we have a
firewall on our side
to make sure that only
the appropriate traffic is
coming back or going to GCP.
And then our internet path
over on the upper right
is basically the same
as non-commerce--
we still use our CDN to direct
the traffic inbound for us.
OK.
So this was a really high level.
What I want to do now is kind
of zoom in to just the GCP
area a little bit
and show you what's
going on there in a
little more detail.
So the first thing
we'll take a look at,
we sometimes jokingly refer
to this as a load balancer
sandwich, but for our
application teams, what
we do is we obviously
have the L7 load
balancer at the edge
for public ingress,
and then we actually have
internal load balancers
that we use for connectivity
either inside the VPC
or from our data
center up into GCP.
Below, what you'll see
in the Platform Services
section is things
got a lot bigger.
We talked about a
lot of these items
already so I'll just gloss
over this really quickly,
but a lot of these services
are common to each environment.
And as I mentioned, we
have proxy and NAT services
available for these
workloads that
need to reach out to
the internet, where
we do police that egress.
If we take a look
in the lower right
and look at the Network
section, there are some things
that we use that are kind
of inherent across all
of these environments.
So we use Cloud VPN and
Cloud Router together.
And what we actually
do in these scenarios
is we use BGP to announce
the routes across.
So this is really great.
This saves us a lot
of time from having
to try to figure out how we
announce these static routes
and putting all these
change requests in.
It makes things really easy
for us and it makes failover
really easy for us as well.
We have Cloud firewall
rules, as I mentioned,
which are inherent across
all of these environments,
and there are many
of them, and then
we use custom
routes to do things
like pull traffic destined to
the internet through our NATs.
So there really isn't a
good way for applications
to egress out any other
way than through our NAT.
In the upper right--
we'll kind of just
gloss over these a little
bit, but we use many other GCP
offerings.
We can see a sampling up there.
So we use IM very heavily.
We use logging in Cloud
Pub/Sub, which has actually
been very helpful to us.
So what we do is we
have logging syncs
on a lot of our
Stackdriver topics
and we pull that into
Pub/Sub, and then
what we do at our data center
is subscribe to that topic
and ingest that.
So instead of clouding up or
filling up our VPN tunnels
to and from GCP, we basically
transmit that out of band
and pull it into our data
center, where it's logged,
stored, and analyzed.
And then finally, the last
piece that I want to touch on
are the Cloud Armor
and SSL policies
that we apply to all
of our load balancers
at the edge to make sure that
we have consistency in the way
that those endpoints
are accessed.
So just quickly going through
some highlights, things
that have been really great
for us over the past year,
the global L7 load
balancers, as I said earlier,
have been really great.
We're big fans of it and
I don't think we really
have any complaints
about it whatsoever.
Inter-region networking
has been great for us.
So this was something
that we were
able to adopt when
we moved to GCP
and it's basically built in.
It's really quick.
It's really easy.
We have absolutely no
complaints about it,
and for some of our services--
so for example, a lot
of our data persistence
is stored in Cassandra.
We can just replicate
across regions
without having to worry
about regional VPCs
and peering those VPCs
together, or even going
to the level of running
VPNs in those VPCs
and then connecting
VPNs together
to get traffic across them.
So that's been great.
Our IPsec VPNs have
been absolutely stable
and we've had a really
great success with those.
The only reason
that we're looking
at moving to Interconnect
is we need a little more
bandwidth than what the VPNs
can currently provide us with.
Cloud Armor has been fantastic.
That has been in place in
our commerce environment
since day one and
we're currently
finishing a rollout in our
non-commerce environment
as well.
A little tidbit that
isn't talked about very
often is the NTP server that is
built into the metadata server.
So this is great.
What it does is it gives you
access to Google's NTP servers,
and you actually get
the time smearing
that Google provides with their
public time.google.com server
as well.
So the great thing
here is we don't
have to configure anything.
This is all kind of
baked in and good to go
and we don't have to egress out
to the internet for NTP sync.
So that's been really handy.
Private IP Google access,
I touched on that already.
That's been really great for us.
Another really great feature
that thankfully we've
only run into one
time is the ability
to expand your subnets live.
I think a lot of folks know
that no matter how you plan
and how many
whiteboards you draw on
and how many spreadsheets
you fill out,
trying to set up your IP
space for cloud deployment,
something unexpected
always happens.
And in those cases, what's
actually really easy to do
in Google is if you haven't
consumed the space that
you'll be expanding to, you
can flip that /24 to a 23
or beyond, as long as
that space is available,
and you can do that live.
So it's a really good
way if the unexpected
has happened for you to get a
little headroom for yourself.
And then finally, Cloud DNS.
Cloud DNS has been
great for us, and our,
as I mentioned
earlier, developers
love it to kind of
be in control of DNS
and do that in a
self-service fashion.
So then I want to just wrap up
with our lessons learned here.
One of the biggest ones
is that everyone should
have and exercise DR plans.
We have an internal tool that
we use that basically allows
us to go through all of
our L7 load balancers
and disable traffic
to a given region.
We use this in
emergency situations
or when we have
issues with a stack
in those particular regions,
and for the most part,
it's been working really well.
Typically within
about 15 or 20 minutes
after an incident
is called, we're
able to drain all of the ingress
traffic to a particular region
away and send that
traffic to other regions,
and we just do that with
a simple config change
the load balancers so that's
absolutely great that we're
able to respond in that way.
If you're operating a hybrid
cloud, lots of planning
involved and lots
of communicating
with teams across
the organization.
We've been very lucky to
have really great partner
teams at Target, all the way
from our infrastructure teams
that help us set up the VPNs
through our platform services
teams that we've partnered
with for that data replication
and storage, all the way
up through our app teams.
And one of the things
that we've done
that's been really critical is
sat down with our application
teams and made sure that, as
we're planning things out,
they're included and we take
their feedback into account
as we're building out these
new features for them.
One interesting item is,
be careful of attaching
the same backend service
to multiple load balancers.
We encountered this last
year when we had teams
that, when they're operating
in that load balancer sandwich
model, created a
single backend service
and attached it to both.
And what happened in that
particular scenario is
the signals from
the load balancers
were a little cross-wired
and they were not
able to scale that service based
on RPS from the Layer 7 load
balancer.
So if scaling based on
RPS is important to you,
avoid attaching
your backend service
to multiple load balancers.
One other interesting
piece that has
been a little bit
of an adaptation
for our application teams
and our security teams
is that, with the exception of
Cloud Armor or the network load
balancer, the firewall
rules that you
apply are applied to
the instance itself.
I'm sorry, this actually does
apply to network load balancer.
So for ILBs, for instance,
there is no firewall rule
that you attach
to the ILB, right?
It's the firewall
rule that you attach
to the instance
that actually allows
that traffic through the ILB.
So a little bit of
working to get that
communicated across
all of our teams.
And then finally,
just be wary no matter
what you're doing-- if
they're static or dynamic
announcements-- of what routes
you announce back on premise.
We're lucky to have BGP
route filters in place
on the Target side
of things, but we
actually for a period
of time did wind up
announcing what is actually our
internal DMZ space in our data
centers that we
use in GCP as well.
And that's part of
that kind of separation
that we operate our
non-commerce applications in.
So luckily we had those
filters in place and nothing
bad happened but
just be wary of that.
So I think that
about wraps it up
for me and I'll
turn it back over.
Oh, sorry.
So kind of tying in with
a couple of other things,
I'm sure you'll be hearing
plenty of announcements
through the rest
of this conference
and the rest of this year.
Some things that Target
is looking forward to,
just a variety of enhancements
up here on the screen.
We use ILBs quite heavily and
Cloud Armor quite heavily,
so we're looking forward
to some enhancements there.
We're also looking forward to
some additional Interconnect
locations.
And one of the big items
that we're looking for
is just some
general enhancements
around VPC performance and
some of the managed services
that might be announced
later this year.
So with that, I'll
send it back on over.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]